a nuclear power plant sailing the seas
Russia says it's one of the safest and
cleanest ways to provide energy to
remote areas the academic Lomonosov
combines both the technology of a
nuclear-powered icebreaker and that of a
land-based nuclear plant it took 10
years to design and build the power
plant will be towed by three boats for
more months to the region of Chukotka
5,000 kilometers away on a journey that
could take up to six weeks depending on
the ice the two reactor unit is one of
the key projects of President Putin
so-called northern sea route a faster
sea connection between Europe and Asia
which has become accessible due to a
melting Arctic
despite safety concerns Russia's nuclear
agency says there is very little chance
of a nuclear accidents the nuclear
station is very solid and is not
vulnerable in case of tsunami or another
disaster happens tests have shown that
chances of gigantic asteroid destroying
the earth in the future is twice as high
as internal damage to this reactor but
Greenpeace is not convinced in April
2017 the environmental group protested
against a project calling it Chernobyl
on ice referring to the nuclear disaster
in the Soviet Union in 1986
if the Fukushima nuclear station was
damaged by a tsunami we can only guess
what could happen in this case the place
can be thrown upside down it can be
thrown on to the shore or get damaged a
recent nuclear accident in the north of
Russia which caused the spike in
radiation has also raised concerns with
several nuclear accidents happening in
the past few months and a government
that is tight-lipped about what exactly
has happened people are growing
increasingly suspicious that like in the
time of Chernobyl you
authorities are trying to cover up
incidents of leaked radiation even
though the academic Luminoso will travel
only to sparsely populated areas its
journey will be closely watched Russia's
plans to sell floating nuclear plants to
other countries have also rung alarm
bells according to Greenpeace offshore
reactors will be harder to monitor and
they can fall into the wrong hands
academic Lomonosov will stay in pivec in
Chukotka for at least 10 years before
going back two more months for
maintenance and to dispose of its
nuclear waste step fasten al-jazeera
Moscow